chances are you know someone suffering
from back or neck pain two-thirds of
adults suffer from some level or back or
neck pain at some point in their lives
one of the most common causes of back
and neck pain is degeneration of the
discs the shock absorbers that act as
padding between each link in the spine
the typical surgical treatments for a
degenerated discs are expensive painful
and can actually cause other nearby
discs to break down over time now a team
of researchers have developed a new
technique to grow engineered discs in
the lab first they seeded a disc made of
a hydrogel polymer with stem cells taken
from a goat the seeded disc was then
sandwiched between two pieces of foam
made from a polymer called
polycaprolactone the researchers
implanted the lab-grown discs into the
necks of goats the discs were subjected
to periodic compression tests to compare
their performance to natural ones
researchers found that after eight weeks
the engineered discs ability to
withstand compression became just as
good as the natural discs all of the
goats recovered from the implantation
surgery without complication a possessed
full range of motion and their necks
throughout the study duration we are
unfortunately a long way off from human
trials researchers would like to
continue long term studies of the
effectiveness of the discs and goats and
other larger mammals still this could
mean that in the future those with
end-stage disc degeneration would be
able to turn to discs grown in a lab to
ease their suffering
[Music]
[Music]